Estados Unidos toma medidas para frenar
la migración irregular hacia su
territorio anunciando un pacto con
Colombia y Panamá el secretario de
seguridad Nacional de Estados Unidos
Alejandro mayorcas insistió en que los
migrantes deben Buscar vías legales o de
lo contrario serán devueltos
anunciamos en enero de este año que
hasta 30.000 personas pueden venir a
Estados Unidos desde Cuba Nicaragua
Venezuela y Haití de manera segura
ordenada y sin someterse a la
explotación de Los contrabandistas
los tres países lanzaron una campaña de
dos meses que busca frenar la migración
irregular combatiendo las redes de trata
y tráfico de personas buscando también
mayor inversión en la zona este
encuentro trilateral es también un
llamado de atención para la puesta en
marcha de acciones regionales que logren
atender de manera integral esta
situación el tapón del es uno de los
pasos fronterizos más peligrosos del
planeta es la frontera natural entre
Centroamérica y Suramérica Esta es la
única parte del continente donde se
interrumpe la carretera Panamericana se
trata de una selva frondosa que cada año
se convierte en travesía mortal para
miles de migrantes que buscan el sueño
americano muchos de los migrantes
terminan siendo Víctimas de robo o
violación a manos de bandas criminales
solo en lo que va de 2023 cerca de
90.000 personas provenientes de países
como Venezuela Haití Cuba y Ecuador han
cruzado el Darién una cifra seis veces
mayor a la registrada en el mismo
periodo del 2022 según datos oficiales
de migración Panamá
el acuerdo trilateral entre Estados
Unidos Panamá y Colombia se produce un
mes antes que expire el título 42 que
permitía expulsar a migrantes en la
frontera sur de Estados Unidos por temas
sanitarios por lo que Washington teme Un
aumento significativo del número de
migrantes que podría desbordar sus
capacidades en la frontera